dans un pays en proie à une violente
deuxième vague de la pandémie les
scrutins régionaux et les rassemblements
politiques continue comme si de rien
n'était le premier ministre narendra
modi prêche devant des foules compactes
de milliers de partisans de m le
réalisateur primé internationalement
anurag kashyap est depuis longtemps un
farouche opposant au gouvernement maudit
comme tant d'autres à bollywood
il a subi la censure grandissante depuis
l'arrivée au pouvoir du premier ministre
nationaliste hindoue cette scène de
trois minutes du film and martial sorte
il y a trois ans a été coupée sans
l'accord du réalisateur la raison on
voit un personnage sic fumée des gens
proches du pouvoir
attaques sur les réseaux sociaux ma
fille et les membres de ma famille je
vis constamment sous pression dit il le
fondateur d'un des rares médias
indépendants indien explique que les
journalistes et les médias d'information
sont harcelés par le gouvernement même
pour des choses banales comme des
gazouillis le site de wire couvre au
quotidien le conflit agricole depuis
novembre dernier et critique la gestion
gouvernementale de la crise cette
couverture ont valu aux fondateurs et à
une jeune journaliste d'être poursuivi
pour dissémination de rumeurs
et incitation à la sédition winter is he
can't hide in motion ce journaliste
d'enquêté ça peut être cette équipe
tiennent un registre de toutes les
pressions sur les journalistes indiens
il précise que les groupes de presse
critique du gouvernement perdre l'accès
au principal annonceur soit le
gouvernement indien
al'inverse ceux qui font des reportages
flatteur pour le gouvernement reçoive un
accès privilégié aux élus même si m le
mois dernier trois organismes
indépendants basés en suède en
angleterre et aux états unis ont
rétrogradé l'aide oran d'autocratie
électorale le pays était autrefois la
plus vaste démocratie du monde
il est maintenant classé parmi les états
jugés partiellement libres comme la
pologne la hongrie et la turquie y ait
beaucoup de jeunes le choc
selon les rapports de freedom house et
intelligence unit les opposants au
gouvernement sont qualifiés d' ennemis
de la nation et les contre-pouvoirs
comme les médias et le judiciaire qu'ont
vu leur indépendance attaquer et éroder
ils disent essentiellement que l'inde
est une dictature soutient même
l'arrière petit fils du père de la
nation le mahatma gandhi il ajoute que
le gouvernement maudit s'est servi du
conflit agricole et de la pandémie pour
restreindre davantage des libertés les
plateformes de diffusion sont les plus
récentes victimes de ce resserrement des
lois décrété à la fin février permettent
au ministère de l'information de
modifier ou même de couper des scènes le
gouvernement maudit est prête à tout
pour promouvoir l'idéologie
fondamentalistes et d'où il ferait même
pression sur les amazon netflix et
autres plateformes pour qu'ils arrêtent
de collaborer avec des réalisateurs
indésirables conséquence autocensure et
isolement pour ceux qui osent s'exprimer
malgré les pressions et l' isolement il
entend demeurer en inde pour continuer
son art et sa contestation du
gouvernement maudit les prochaines
années feront foi de tout d'ailleurs
selon l'éditeur cette accroche autres
iphone
il veut croire que son pays fera le
choix de la liberté et que les indiens
pourront voter sans contrainte et en
toute confiance aux prochaines élections
générales prévues dans trois ans
et c'est philippe leblanc radio-canada
délit